so this is the great Birdman
you got the roaming in the desert and
evils is torturing me and they're
supposed to look for this mysterious
Birdman who they don't know if he's good
or bad and it turns out most idli flies
rode pooping fire yes and they find them
and it turns out it's I forget his name
yeah zodiac the Goblin that like to
spank people and but his eyes were taken
away by a wizard when really they were
just put in his beard but he seems nicer
and he can manipulate sort of time and
space to give take other people's pain
and give it to himself and exchange wins
and such and he these birds with his
nipples I'm pretty disturbing best thing
in this little episode was watching this
knowing that scene coming up watching
Jory and just being like like I can't do
the disgusted look because when it cuts
to Finn and Jake and they're just like
like oh my god that's pretty much
exactly what Doug yeah maybe just the
enjoyed a staredown it's just like
awesome and so the debate wouldn't have
to tell about his eyes cuz they knew he
was evil but they're convinced he's
changed so they finally tell him about
human back his eyes we get shouldn't be
sawing sequence and sure enough he tries
to return to his kingdom to take it back
because with his eyes he feels you know
he has strength again if he wants to in
the war power and he gets jealous and he
wants his power back and he starts to
abuse it and the birds fly away cuz I
see he's not the same person that you
know raised them and he tells Ben to
take his eyes and bury him they just put
it back in his beard and he goes off
into the distance to see if he can find
peace and he finds a girlfriend a
mermaid and it stops
so definitely some good lansinoh like I
said that difficult thing was hilarious
um I really like been putting the eyes
back in the beard sort of like you know
I'll give you another chance sort of
thing I thought you know I sort of when
he's ready to discover it or see it
again or maybe when the time comes again
like he'll have an option again I like
that like what I just thought he's an
idiot he'll never think they're actually
here again that's how I took I never
actually even thought about it that way
but yeah okay I sort of see it that way
cuz they're you know he's even like you
know I hope he finds peace man I'll be
level of everything you know the fact
they took about to bury him anyway you
know sort of the sense of he really does
feel something um so this is sort of a
nice little tragic you know story there
that without his sight because we're
humbled but then what it's back he goes
right back to the do she was uh and he's
aware of it it seems like um once once
he started spanking the bird and you
know he looked at the burden of blurred
it's like what do you do like all like
teary-eyed he's like oh crap I totally
screwed up I'm really glad they went
that direction because when you see him
go back to the kingdom I'm already
seeing like okay it's I can't see where
it's going okay give it back the ice gun
turn back into a jerk again I'm since I
know it's coming up sir like okay can we
speed along whatever so when they get to
the kingdom it just that to the birds
and the brief fly away I like that like
how quickly they wrap that off mm-hmm um
and we didn't spend too much time like
trying to stop him or take him down
whatever oh so yeah I like it it's good
I get the feeling I feel like I've seen
this episode a few times where has the
bad guy changed as they really have they
really change their ways and nine out of
ten they never do and that's kind of a
on me because I've seen so many times
it's a bit of a bore um but like I said
but I like I like they realizes it again
a takes his eyes out and a guy like that
pinpoints it back in the beard throwing
around a girlfriend
you know ok whatever so it's whatever I
mean it likes it the nipple thing really
had her jaws on the ground and laughs
and so it's it's fine it's okay yeah my
problem was I liked it it was okay
such a good build-up the the the
people's joke Oh
turns out they're just lonely haha which
makes me think of Nelson from The
Scindia you know so when she the
bizarrely mean even for her like she
says she's always revealed to have kind
of dark sides she's always had this dark
side to her and that just seemed like
particularly mean-spirited yeah um it
makes me laugh so we go from there
you know them wandering hid them meeting
Sergey AK again with the eyes I was
great and then of course you know
because he walked up to the little birds
and you expect him to go blue there you
know some on those lines feeding birds
but then this is a nipple thing but the
light from there just kind of slowly
loses steam and you're right like you
kind of see exactly where it's going
it's no real surprise and I mean I don't
know I guess you're right with the whole
I've seen it a million times you know oh
oh has the evil guy reformed and it's
like well yeah he was reformed
he was completely reformed he was
completely fine until Finn and Jake came
along and screwed things up well unless
needed all bhakti no Peebles though
people's did send them out so it's
people's fault
the one thing I do really like the whole
thing with the eyes and the beard yeah
that seems very much like a traditional
fable you know something where I think
there's a keynote journey where like
she's tell a story about you know it's a
made-up story but she says how this tank
is look you know his master sent him to
find the other tank that has you know
that killed him and it has three red
stripes and like a drawing of a bull on
there or something like that
and you know ask keno have you seen this
tank and she says no and he said oh then
my search continues and he turns around
she sees that tank had the three red
stripes and the bullets so it's always a
continuing journey they'll never have
thanks thanks for ruining that story
well no that's like the opening of that
story to be fair like okay he knows
journey is like a million of those okay
you should take like an actual tank and
that's all a tank test yeah interesting
yeah no it's it's a real good I
advertised it before on my face but um
sikinos journey go check it out like the
one anime I know that even a lot of
anime buffs don't know so it's like my
one okay that's what I haven't heard I'm
not a huge anime buff but yeah I've
never heard about yeah it's really good
go check it out but um but yeah I saw I
serve like those timeless stories of you
know it sort of the endless tragedy of
something and I yeah I do like how the
eyes were always there and it's sort of
like will he ever discovery will he not
and I like he's start giving the
opportunity again you know sort of to
maybe have this awakening and maybe that
was it maybe Finn and Jake were not
supposed to tell him he was supposed to
discover for him yeah yeah so I like
that again I'll I really like that Finn
puts it back in the beard no I I agree I
mean obviously I don't blame Finn or
Jake or anything like that but it's like
they just didn't put the damn ice back
and they said they work grapes it'd all
be fine yeah but you can see why though
he seemed to him do you know change and
swish around but yeah it was not it's in
this story anyway it did not seem like
their place to do so
yeah but then again I do like that you
know Finn knows about twin Jake was like
no we shouldn't say something come on
it's only change so at least they
weren't like that's girl we'll just do
it anyways you know yeah I mean what
it's a good guy level and it's you know
fair enough I like that you know there
are some times where it's and it's not
very clear but there are some times
where it's like you know it's just gotta
let a person be enough intervene there's
so many people have such a hard time
with that you know that I can't just let
a prison be I always have to be there I
have to feel needed and I have to save
people I have to and there are
definitely people like that and but
there are instances where it's like that
will make it worse
yeah you know but it's hard to say when
I mean that's one of the hardest things
about being a person it's like when do
you
just let a person be and when do you
intervene you know it's not easy it's
really hard so I do like that about the
episode but yeah I'm with you it's the
fact that you know exactly where it's
gonna go and you're just sir like okay
let's sort of speed it up here a bit but
oh one thing I forgot that I thought was
great and so just like why he's talking
to peoples on the communicator I was
like okay bye and he just Hux it yeah
it's like why does he just like it's
like what the heck maybe because she was
underwater and he's like god that sounds
nice right now so I don't know
I know step out for a quick second let
George say anything if she wants to do
business is a people hate comments you
almost got people back with the Martian
we love it now you just got send it
right back to the crapper no I'm sorry
but I don't know how anybody could
possibly defend that whole mermaid
incident that's that that I don't defend
it I think it's just like it's like
she's always so nice and princessy and
stuff and that she'll just have these
really sick demented moment that's like
what the hell where's the backup I'm
just saying I told you also people's
love I'm not a hater I'm just me yeah
could you hear that head smacking from
there Jason let a huge kids neck
Simon and Marci what the hell we doing
still talking we're gonna add a Miss a
bye